Brooks koepka recently donated $100,000
to his foundation and will go directly
to the Community Foundation's Cova 19
response fund for Palm Beach and Martin
counties and Brooks koepka who I believe
just turned 30 a couple of days ago
joins us on the program
hey good morning Brooks how are you I'm
doing okay would you do for your 30th
birthday just hung out of the house and
just relaxed here and celebrated and
just trying to make the best of a bad
situation
I heard that you went alcohol-free for a
little while yeah I did I did I went 30
days they didn't go 31 so no chance it
was very tempting that was 31
what's your go-to make a little bullet
row I like Michelob Ultra it's good man
it's nice it's perfect especially down
here man it's warm it's fun part for the
pool I why is it like dogs going nuts
what kind of dog you got I got a black
lab my god she's taking her out now
that's I why is it I play better when
I've had a couple of beers I'm playing
golf ah it it's so funny everybody just
gets so relaxed and it feels you know
they're not afraid to screw up anymore
it's amazing you watch guys it's
literally there's that right zone that's
gotta be in yeah you can get over-served
a little bit too much and then then it's
not very good and then your game goes to
crap but there's there's a right amount
you got to find that perfect amount for
you there is a fine line where it's like
darts or bowling where you go man I'm
killing it and then you have that next
beer and you're go on getting killed I'm
not any good at this
yeah that's way it's amazing every I
mean you watch it every amateur and then
you know especially like the pro-am
sometimes you guys are so nervous when
they're playing with us you're like I
mean I know it's early
but you want to you want to have a drink
and you know help loosen him up and make
some fun have you ever played in a
program where the amateur was playing
better than you uh I don't think so but
I had to think about it so I don't know
that's a good do you ever have bets with
people where because what what would you
be a plus seven plus six I guess yeah if
you put it in that somewhere around
there yeah well I'll bet I'll bet the
guys every once in a while and see what
they've got it's fun and you watch them
you watch them get a little nervous and
you know because they're obviously it's
fun for them they're taking it really
really seriously as they show that I
mean I'm I would oppose in that
situation and yeah they try to they try
to take some dollars office yeah but you
you appeared to be it like stealth with
your trash talk like I don't strike me
as outwardly but it feels like you could
be pretty good with just a side little
jab there how would you rate your game
um yeah I mean I like my trash-talking
skills
I like I'm pretty good when you played
you overdo it kind of just as I walked
by a little bit you know so you don't
good to see him here to really say
anything back you can't you can't do
anything like just a whisper yeah just
enough word you know I'm walked by
Tamayo he definitely heard me
but he might might have you know you're
not really sure when you played with
Jordan trash talk yeah yeah I did I mean
you have to why not and then he shut me
out pretty quick nothing thought that
was four or five years ago later that
how does he shut you up uh we were
playing we're playing on old palm I
think down here in Florida yeah MJ he
was up I he was up on me a little bit
earlier then I got up on him finally and
turned the tables and then we're on
sixteen or we're walking on 17 tee and
I'm giving him shots in 17 and 18 and I
forget what I said I said something to
him any any tease the ball up he takes a
practice swing and he goes it's
fourth-quarter baby I don't lose
here we go this is this is the MJ I
remember
and then obviously goes on to win 17 and
then he just kind of looked at me on 18
T and then 18 green I think he should he
shook my hand I want to know where my
where my wallet was everything but his
tiger are there parallels with that
competitiveness with tiger and Mike I
think so I think there is I think you
look at it with every great athlete
that's ever come across their sport and
I mean we're talking the best of the
best and that competitiveness is is
there it doesn't matter if they're
playing cards
ping-pong golf basketball whatever it is
they they just can't they refuse to lose
now you strike me as a guy that needs
action my golf would be boring it for a
guy like you like you play basketball is
golf boring to you I think I think it
just gets because it what I say it's
boring upset it's boring it just takes a
very very long time to complete and a
dot to me is where I need the action the
excitement yeah you hit a great shot but
then you've still got five minutes
before you walk up to go tap it in for
birdie so it's like a five-minute like
dull period of you know you don't know
what the other guys doing to you can be
making a mess of the whole searching for
balls and you know I just need that
constant action more more probably more
than other guys how often you play
basketball
ah we were messing around the pool
yesterday was two days ago
shooting around but uh no Ivan I haven't
touched rim in a long time could you
dunk I could I remember I forget where I
was a couple years ago maybe two three
years ago we were in like a LA Fitness
and you know those gyms are so packed
but is late at night so I just grabbed
the ball went in there and two down
twice wait was it a rub dunk where you
just just get it over the rim yeah there
were a couple attempts before
it was very very close and then I made I
made it quite interesting that's all you
did you left them with an image and
that's all you need it's just AIDS cap
kit was here and he was Duncan yeah
exactly all it takes is one person to
see it yeah
the next next event you're playing in is
what over the first week back is it
supposed to be a colonial right now
which i think is the week of June 8th I
believe right now yeah yeah whenever
that whenever that first tournament is
I'm gonna be there I'm gonna be ready
it's just exciting just to have
something to look forward to I think
that was that was what was killing
everybody is the unknown you know you're
sitting there okay you're trying to
Train you're trying to do everything you
know the best you can you don't have
weights here how'd you go get some you
just you're not used to doing the things
that you're used to doing so just to
have something back now where it's okay
we can get back into the into the swing
of things and start looking forward to
to playing golf again and competitively
because it's one thing to just go play
with your boys and then it's gonna play
another thing like I should go out and
go to it up in a real thing how do you
think the pandemic is going to affect
golf though when you come back it's
gonna be interesting I think yeah I
think it's gonna be interesting when the
fans come back obviously look as an
athlete nobody wants to be playing just
without fans it's it's what creates the
energy but I think now looking at it
it's gonna be interesting how close
they're gonna be able to let fans
because golf I mean if you've ever been
to Augusta I mean you can stand on those
tea boxes and you can pretty much reach
out and grab the guy as he's swinging
you can get pretty close to us and you
just wonder how how weird it is gonna be
going forward you know whether they're
gonna be pushed back further you know
you look at like an NBA or baseball do
they redo the seating a little bit you
know you never know what's gonna happen
but hopefully and hopefully we just get
fans I mean that's where the energy is
that's what makes it fun and
who doesn't love you know hidden like a
crowd-pleaser and everybody goes nuts
I had the Commissioner on a couple of
weeks ago and I said why don't you and I
brought this up to Bubba Watson I said
why don't you guys just carry your own
bags
that that way I take the Caddy out of
this so even more social distancing like
let's see who can carry their own sticks
and what do you think it'd be
interesting I think it'd actually be a
lot of fun just to watch some of these
guys attempt to carry their own bag I
don't think some of them ever picked up
their bag in their life who wouldn't
make it 18 holes care in their own bag
who wouldn't make it 18 carrying the bag
[Music]
I don't know I actually don't think
Bubba would be complaining I love the
guy but there's no way he makes it
around 18 with that bag any always
complaining about something yeah it's
great I love it yeah I think it's
hilarious he's a good dude he's good
dude deep down you just gotta get to
know what do you think Thanksgivings
gonna be like it Augusta that's gonna be
way different helping anybody know even
what to expect it's gonna be so cold
it's gonna be it's balls not to be
flying far is it over seated what are
they gonna do they're actually gonna be
rough those holes are gonna play long
the wind direction I think switches I
don't know that for a fact but somebody
told me that a couple weeks ago it's
every par-5 basically plays into the
wind from what I was told so it's gonna
change the golf course I think you'll
see scores around even par instead of
that 12 15 under the year you've been
accustomed to and I think it could
really affect that back nine
you see obviously 11 is hard 12 there's
plenty of water balls 13 you might not
be able to get there anymore mm mm 15
being the par 5 you know it might not be
as exciting it was it finished I was
able to play a gust to a couple of times
and I came back and told my friends I
said you know what's weird is you stand
on 12 and you're playing 12
just like everybody plays 12 I'm playing
at the same yardage that you are and you
stand there and you go when you watch on
TV you go why is that a big deal and
then you get there on 12 and you go 11
pin I'm looking at the flag 13 tee box
the trees I'm looking at the how they're
blowing like you you factor in its
sensory overload there with a shot
that's what 149 or something like that
and it and it's like you you get demons
in your head what what do you think when
you get to 12 you try to think as little
as possible you got I'll never forget
like last year when I did in the water
on on Sunday it's interesting cuz I
actually backed off the shot before
before I went in yeah because you felt
the wind direction you know I think it
was just supposed to be a little bit in
and maybe out of the right and or no
supposed me you're not the left and I
felt they go in off the right so it just
kind of confuses you a little bit and
then all of a sudden you back off and
then I look over 11-pin like you said
and now it's going downwind you're like
come on then you know you look up at the
trees and 13 and they're going sideways
and then it doesn't feel like there's
anything it's just you got to hit it at
the right time and get quite lucky to be
honest with you it's it's interesting
and then on top of that you got
everybody hooting and hollering when it
goes in the water and it's just it could
be it could be a really great tea box if
you hit the green and it is miserable
when you got to walk another 100 yards
I'm probably being drop and those fans
are right on you I mean that the holes
are so compacted I mean they're there
they're right there as if they're
walking with you they're carrying your
bag I mean they're so close to you what
kind of grief did they give you on 12 on
Sunday I just remember I remember
actually laughing I heard some guy just
clears throat a couple times
what is it decision choking yeah here a
couple you can hear a couple of I mean I
don't listen we get paid to put up with
that stuff it's on but I actually
enjoyed you know the more in the morning
these fans get into it
they chirp I mean it's fun I would do
the same thing if I was out there
watching do they make you laugh oh yeah
yeah I have to I won't respond to I
usually don't respond to it unless it's
quite funny I'll engage in them but
other than that you know I try to try to
keep it to them and because you never
know what's gonna come out
Brooks recently donated $100,000 to the
Brooks koepka foundation that will go
directly to Community Foundation's Cova
19 response fund for Palm Beach and
Martin counties hair looks good looks
nice and tight there on the sides your
girlfriend do the honors there yeah yeah
it's coming back I think you should get
a mullet well for a while I wasn't sure
if I was gonna have anything man well I
didn't know what was gonna I mean this
side you could still see a little
there's like it's like a vanilla ice
where he had the lightning bolt in the
side of his yeah actually that would
have been a great little coverup to you
start throwing those stripes down the
side you can still do it you got a
little time before you get down to the
house it's always great always great to
talk to you Brooks we appreciate the
time and we'll look forward to seeing
you in June yep you got it thanks